Behind every house in storefront burn.
There is, of course, a story.
A family
who lost a home full of memories,
a business owner
whose years of hard work
literally went up in flames.
And my next guest suffered that loss.
Iconic artist
Ruby Maze are best known for this.
The first mouth and tongue
ever created for the Rolling Stones,
which was featured
prominently
on the Tumbling Dice record
sleeve back in 1971.
He was about to open a new gallery
on Front Street in Lahaina.
100 of his paintings were lost.
And Ruby joins me now
Ruby, thanks so much for taking the time
to talk to us.
And we're so sorry
for everything you've lost.
Can you explain what happened Tuesday
when the fires began?
I know you were at home
in a different community in Maui.
Your sons were at your gallery
on Front Street in Lahaina
preparing for its grand opening, right?
Correct.
Yeah, it was.
We've been waiting for this
Maui location,
which is right next to Fleetwoods.
And when we found it,
we moved
the gallery from Waikiki over to Maui.
So we shipped over
a hundred paintings here.
I live up in Kula upcountry
And my three sons have been working
in the track lighting
and the painting in the building
and the furniture
and hanging the paintings.
And we decided, Okay,
we're going to be ready
Tuesday for the grand opening.
And Monday night,
they were in the gallery
and people
coming in already
and saying, Oh, I want to buy this.
I want to buy this.
And my son said, You know what?
My dad's going to be here tomorrow night.
You bought from him before.
He would love to
say hello to you and wish you happiness
and whatever
Come back tomorrow for the grand opening.
And they said, no, we want to buy it now.
And they said, No, no, tomorrow.
So they said, Okay.
And
the next day I was up at my house
and the winds were like
100 miles per hour.
And I have £150 mass of a good bear walk.
And my son's called and said, Dad, it's
really getting bad.
I said, Well,
better
come on
back here,
because it's
not looking good here either.
And they came up.
They tried to get out of Lahaina,
and they were
closing down the road
because of the flames,
and they got out.
But it was a miracle they got out.
They came up to my house
and they saw all the furniture, my deck,
everything was being
thrown around like toothpicks.
And they go, Dad, we got to go now.
And I said, you know what?
If it's going to be
really bad, let's get a hotel room.
Not one hotel had a room available.
Nothing.
We were calling 15 hotels, not one room.
So my other son said, You know what?
Let's get a U-Haul.
Look, okay,
we got to you all.
So we went to Walmart,
bought blow up beds,
and then we had four dogs in the car.
We'd walk to blow up beds, blankets,
sheets, pillows, bottles of water.
And we went to two U-Haul to the parking
lot of the airport to sleep there.
And the next thing we knew,
Lino was gone.
I know it's completely gone.
My lifelong work of 50
years, painting rockstars stars
got
and I've been having calls
from people, collectors
from all over the world.
And last night,
one collector called back and
she said, Ruby,
this painting
we bought
from you a couple of years ago,
we paid a lot of money for it.
We'd like to send it back to you
so you could sell it and get some money.
And people are amazing.
Ruby, I can't imagine
what it's like for you now.
When you saw the images of Front Street,
you know,
not just your gallery in ruins, but
but all your artwork gone,
what went through your mind?
Well,
John, I just beat cancer
for the third time.
I had bladder cancer.
I had a brain tumor.
They gave me six months to live.
And this last year,
I had a bout with throat cancer.
So I figured if I could beat cancer
three times, nothing can take me down.
And then
losing my life's work
and almost losing my three sons
on Front Street.
It's a lot to take,
a lot to take.
And a little ray of sunshine was.
I went up the back road today
to see if my house was in ashes as well.
And I pulled up around the corner,
and it was smoky and stinky.
From the fire.
And there was my house standing.
It did not burn down
among all those burnt and down
trees and power lines.
And
my house is still there.
We wish you all the best.
I know that
so many of your fans will rally again,
rally around you in this time of need.
So all the best to you, Ruby.
To you and your family. Be well
done.
Thank you very much.